a judge could decide today whether
former Penn State fraternity brothers
will stand trial in connection with the
death of pledged Timothy Piazza the
prosecution presented the fraternity
brothers text messages yesterday in
court they shed light on their
conversations following the 18-year olds
death Piazza died in February after
hazing ritual at the Beta Theta Pi house
that involved heavy drinking Jericka
Duncan is at the courthouse in
Bellefonte Pennsylvania Eureka Eureka
good morning good morning in those text
messages some of the fraternity brothers
showed that they were very concerned
about what those messages said as well
as trying to keep this issue quiet the
other messages that we heard about in
court yesterday show that these frat
brothers spent nearly $2,000 on alcohol
for the night of the alleged ritual
known as the gauntlet at 16 members of
Beta Theta Pi looked on in court Monday
the prosecution presented text messages
that revealed panic amongst some of the
frat brothers chapter president Brendan
young texted his girlfriend after
Timothy Piazza was taken to the hospital
he looked expletive dead at the end of
the day I am accountable for it all
pledge master Daniel Casey texted his
girlfriend to say we are expletive like
beyond expletive and another message
young says to Casey
make sure the pledges clean the basement
and get rid of any evidence of alcohol
attorneys for some of the defendants
accused district attorneys Stacey Parks
Miller of cherry-picking messages I'm a
little surprised at the nature of the
charges and Rocco sipper own represents
Michael Bonaduce one of the 18
fraternity members facing wide-ranging
charges in connection with Piazza's
death I think the evidence will show as
it progresses that he left that betahaus
even before the first fall mr. Piazza
ever occurred did not return according
to a grand jury presentment Piazza fell
down a flight of stairs the night of the
alleged hazing ritual known as the
gauntlet the Penn State sophomore
suffered multiple traumatic brain
injuries and a shattered spleen an
investigator testified the pledges were
not physically forced to drink Tom Klein
is representing the Piazza family
this was not a voluntary drinking
situation
Tim Piazza was force-fed alcohol in
order to get acceptance into this group
like the 47 other pledges in 2016 and
2017 were required to do these horrible
things now one person not facing
criminal charges is the assistant
athletic director at Penn State tim
bream now he was actually living in the
fraternity house Penn State says that he
was acting as a living adviser not as a
representative for the university he
admits to seeing a portion of that night
but says it was alcohol-free we did ask
for bream to comment and he declined
Noora another part of this story Jericka
thank you so much